since phantom blood kicked off the
modern franchise in 2012
jojo's bizarre adventure has caused
nothing short of a cultural revolution
within the realm of anime
from the series receiving a brand
spanking new adventure theme park
a status only reached by other notable
names like one piece in tokyo tower
and the studio ghibli museum dedicated
to the entirety of miyazaki's iconic
films
to tick-tock trends to art books this
series has
surely cemented itself across a wide
variety of mediums
in the history books of us weebs
and with the recent announcement of part
6 stone ocean
being slated for an anime adaptation the
fire within jojo stands across the world
has rekindled the ororas the muramuras
[Music]
get ready to hear these sound bites left
and right spamming them in the chat as
we rise up
and for you poor souls who aren't on
board yet who haven't gone through the
rite of passage that is jojo's bizarre
adventure
now is that time sail into the
magnificent sunset with us as we explore
this beautiful
strange bizarre ocean a stone ocean
if you will and also the 95
of you who aren't on board yet subscribe
and like
and roll the intro
jojo's bizarre adventure is incredibly
hard to describe
but the one word in my mind that i
always think of is
unique when someone asks me if they
should watch
jojo while my internal mind is screaming
i almost always tell them yeah you
should it's one of the most unique anime
i've ever watched
from the art style to the whole concept
and how it drastically shifts
between different tones and genres it's
truly a wild card
one where i'm sure that even if you
don't love everything about the show
you'll find at least one thing just
because
there's so much the first and most
notable to an outside viewer i think
is the art style there's truly no other
anime that can even compare to jojo's
bizarre adventures art style
not to say it's like the best art style
of all time but more so like it's so
distinct that comparing it to others
just doesn't really feel right
the skies are colored in different
palettes and the normal colors of
characters are often inverted for
special effects like surprise or shock
which would normally feel really weird
and really strange to see
like imagine if you're watching attack
on titan and then big monkey boy just
goes
[Music]
like it doesn't feel right it doesn't
feel like an actual anime
it's abrasive but in jojo i think
because of the tone of the show
and the extremely out of ordinary
character designs
it somehow works i mean there's stands
of
all kinds which are all colored and
designed in such alien ways
for anyone who's really interested in
art and wants to see just how far anime
can take
manga and put it into a colored and
animated medium
jojo is certainly a must-watch but what
am i thinking
i got so caught up in the beauty of it
all that i forgot the most bizarre part
of all
the power system let me get some
background before i get into that like
the plot
but actually that's kind of difficult
i'll give an abridged version
essentially we follow a bloodline of
jojo's
starting from jonathan joestar to joseph
joestar to jotaro cujo
to josuke to giorno and now in stone
ocean jolene
and the plot changes with each new main
character from fighting vampires in part
one to fighting
old powerful like mayan dudes who came
from stone to part two
to like fighting a bunch of mercenaries
to random people to mafia members
oh my god there's so much we follow all
these different characters in the
separate parts of the series so we
already get an extremely diverse set of
main protagonists
and their parts respective antagonists
and on top of that we have the power
system stands
stands are again up there in my opinion
with nen from hunter hunter and chakra
from naruto for being one of the best
power systems in anime and if not the
best then one of the most
iconic stands are basically
visual materializations of someone's
life energy
they have varying abilities from cool
fighters to weird like
gremlin boys to whatever your heart can
imagine
and most if not all of the main
characters both good
and evil have one i mean if you haven't
watched it to give you scope
there's dozens upon dozens of episodes
of jojo's now
almost all of which feature a new
antagonist every episode who has a
different stand
there's grateful dead which makes people
age the hotter their body temperature
gets
and then there's cheap trick a little
baby looking dude who attaches to
people's backs
and drains their life force and then
transfers between people
only if they see that person's back like
some of these are just so obscure
it makes jojo's super unpredictable you
never really know what's coming next or
how these stands will interact with each
other each scenario is very different
because of the stands in play so the
show never really
feels complacent it stays changing
and then you've also got the tone of
jojo's bizarre adventure or
more specifically the combination of
extreme masculinity vs
gender bending poses and feminine styles
the series started off more so on the
former side with jonathan being like the
most
masculine dude you'll ever see and
joseph's pretty similar
and jotaro is literally just an insanely
jacked high schooler who has an
even more jacked stand and goes around
beating up people with brute force
more often than not you know how they're
like really obscure and niche stand
powers
jyotaro fast strong boy
plus a little bit of
but in parts four five and six now we're
seeing the show stray away from that
into more flamboyant styles from
josuke's pompadour to giorno's bright
pink getup
to i mean a girl in stone ocean as the
main character
and this shift has been arguably
essential to the series growth i think
the very norm defying poses that
tick-tock has made into a trend from dio
to the more colorful backgrounds and
outfits in recent parts
with the diversity that multiple parts
and protagonists offer to the series
jojo's bizarre adventure is able to
change its tone so easily to reel in so
many more fans
it keeps getting bigger and more crazy
with each new stand and character who's
introduced
and because there's so much going on
there are times when the show kind of
strays away from the main plot
to address you know new stands or random
enemies
we see this in part 3 with jotaro where
like the first 30 episodes of the series
it's just him and his gang
fighting a new enemy each episode we
also see this a lot in part 4 which has
a very different feel from a lot of the
jojo's series
but also in say part 1 and 2 and 5 it
focuses very heavily on the overarching
plot and goals
so the show does have this duality to it
which i don't think is bad actually i
think focusing on characters over the
plot is important to flesh out the jojo
world and the people who inhabit it and
their stands of course
i mean this video has basically just
turned into a really long rant about the
many good parts of jojo
but i mean i just kind of wanted to talk
about it now that stone ocean is
announced i mean everyone is hype
all of my friends are talking to me
about how hype jojo is going to be
and i'm excited are you guys leave a
comment down below if you're excited for
jojo's what you think about stone ocean
or what you think about the series in
general
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]
you